now since the beginning of Russia's war
of aggression against Ukraine moscow's
commercial aviation industry has taken a
heavy hit
industry Giants such as Airbus and
Boeing stopped supplying spare parts to
Russia back in March so how is Russia's
commercial aviation industry holding up
more than nine months later DW's Killian
buyer takes a closer look
despite the sanctions and being cut off
from the deliveries of critical
components Russian Airlines are still
operating even though there has been a
15 to 20 percent drop in passengers for
most people taking domestic flights in
Russia not much has changed
in terms of flying jets it was always
going to take a bit longer because of
course you've got stockpiles and spare
parts and of course you've got the
existing aircraft that could be
cannibalized more than 800 modern
Western built passenger Jets were flown
by Russian commercial airlines before
the outbreak of the war more than half
of their flights operated on
International routes the majority of
these flights have been terminated by
sanctions
International routes were very lucrative
one of the most important forms of
income the harsh cut off from this cash
flow was very serious and on the other
side you had the aviation industry it
has become very difficult to supply
aircraft that are flying now with spare
parts
even before the war Airlines in Russia
face difficulty getting spare parts a
pilot took this video a year ago it
shows yellow slips written with the
letters i-n-o-p meaning inoperable the
situation has worsened drastically since
the war
and Prestige projects like the ms-21 and
the Sukhoi 100 super jet both passenger
aircraft built in Russia have an
Achilles heel they depend heavily on
West
Theory rashetto joins us now he's bureau
chief at our DW studios in Riga ayuri so
it's pretty remarkable that Russian
Aviation roots are still going despite
nearly 10 months of sanctions how is
that even possible
well look at the Russian aviation
industry experienced a kind of shock
immediately after the start of the war
because Russian aircraft were no longer
allowed to fly to the West overnight at
the same time Abus and Boeing ended
their cooperation with Russia and to
this despite the fact that almost all
Russian aircraft came from all come from
Airbus and Boeing but the fact that half
of all Russian planes since then had to
stay on the ground meant that these
planes could be used as spare parts
however the loss of almost 50 percent of
flight routes became a blessing for the
Russian aviation industry so the most
important thing for now for Russians is
to maintain domestic Airlines and so far
this is still working well
so when we hear that domestic Aviation
is still doing well but spare parts are
hard to come by or have to be
cannibalized from older planes surely
there's some safety concerns consider no
yeah sure the question is of course when
the ground at the aircraft will be taken
apart and used as spare parts and for
how long that can last and replace
safety Repairs by the Western companies
we know that Russia has kept all the
aircraft at least from the west by
decree of President Putin after all
that's more than 500 Jets worth over 10
billion dollars one Russian expert we
spoke to a called in just a theft Iran
was also a great hope for Russian
Aviation the country has been living
under sanctions for decades and has
developed various methods to circumvent
them but Iran uses aircraft from the
1970s and 1980s which which are less
dependent on software updates
um Ira float in particular has equipped
its Fleet with very modern aircraft in
recent years that apparently don't need
to be to be repaired so quickly but at
the same time because Russia uses very
modern aircraft that rely on those very
Technologies it will be increasingly
difficult to save safely operate Western
aircraft without computer updates and
Russia itself hardly builds its own
aircraft or at least not nearly enough
so it's going well for now but it might
not go well for longer Yuri Rosetto
bureau chief at our DW pseudos in Riga
thank you very much